you don't know when something unique is
gonna happen out here but you better be
on your toes there is use on top of my
original after a brief stay in Deadhorse
sue has returned home to find a
Wolverine lurking around kavik spur
ammeter to protect herself securing camp
is a priority came in last night got as
much done as I could
noted the Wolverine tracks enter it's a
decent sized Wolverine saw my little
foxy bloodied up I've got up here to
look around just make sure there's no
wolf there's no anything directly in my
path to go from here to the shop and
boom way out here about a mile and a
half is the big Wolverine is that a
threat absolutely they are a force to be
reckoned with and they will take on a
800-pound grizzly and win you know and
it's just one of those things I've got
to make a committed choice do I go after
the Wolverine or do I continue on my
chores if he comes closer in than I got
a there's no choice I gotta go take care
of it I have to get my electric started
I have to check the integrity of camp
out I just don't trust that furry little
I'm gonna go down the road and see what
tracks are there how fresh are they were
they headed make sure that that little
Joker doesn't have a cubby he's coming
up in this little dude has got to taste
the blood in camp I know he hurt slinky
I don't want to be his next meal
this over here little tiny roundish
prints look at the spacing this is a fox
this it's got some snow in it but check
out the size difference right they get
my hand down there boom that is a
Wolverine track you cannot be too
careful here the minute you let your
guard down just put a little ketchup on
yourself and call yourself a pork chop
you're gonna get it again Wolverine
Wolverine tell me the Wolverine is not
do a decked out a little hole by my camp
this is my camp not his he sees it the
other way around so what's the most
imperative thing that I can do today
get my electrics on get those spotlights
on and camp the Predators tend to stay
out of range of the spotlights I'm
hoping that he just says dudes bad
dammit
and he goes away but if he doesn't I
will defend this camp with every piece
of armament that I've got I will defend
my foxes with every piece of armament
that I've got this is my camp